tonight though a look at ccsd's plan on
reopening at schools 8 News Now reporter
or co-manager team is down the newsroom
with the lick a look at the proposal
Barca police and Brian we got a hold of
this presentation which lays out the
most updated reopening plan for Clark
County Schools
it'll be presented to the Board of
Trustees this Thursday now there are
three main recommendations that are put
forth in the proposal for CCSD wants to
create a blended learning plan which
means a mix of in-person instruction and
distance learning students who attend
classes at school two days a week and
they will do online classes three days a
week
second for middle and high school
students year-long courses will be
condensed to one semester and they will
only take four courses per semester and
third the school district is looking at
an adjusted start date for students
which according to the plan will be
August 24th there will also be new
procedures for student drop off food
services and transportation the whole
plan can be found on our website
8 News now.com and will also break it
down tonight at 11:00 now live in the
rusyn newsroom or camana
8 news now